[Music]  my dad believed in you I'm not gonna  make the same mistake you know what  happens to you if you go through with  this I have everything I need to have  you court-martialed and dishonorably  discharged  [Music]  your instructor is one of the finest  pilots this program has ever produced  [Music]  his exploits are legendary what he has  to teach you may very well mean the  difference between life and death your  reputation precedes you  after admit I wasn't expecting an  invitation back  they're called orders  [Music]  good morning aviators this is your  captain speaking  today's exercise is dogfighting two  birds one hey you gotta be kid  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]